Okay.
We're taking live calls earlier this week
because of the 4th of July holiday that is
upcoming at (617) 830-4750.
Let's go.
Uh, let's see.
We've got so many people holding who want
to get on today.
Let's start with our color from the three
three zero area code.
Uh, who's calling today from three three zero
hello, this is Jared.
Hey Jared, what's going on here?
Ah, yeah, I'm from Youngstown, Ohio.
I just wanted to know your opinion on what
regular people could do to deal with this
issue of like child concentration camps and
just concentration camps generally.
Yeah.
The progressive with the correct policy, uh,
going for on this cause it's not enough to
just go back to like Obama era policy keeping
families together and these privately run
concentration camps we have to do obviously
something more.
So I'd just like to hear your thoughts on
that.
Yeah.
This entire situation has been um, sort of
held hostage by creeping normalization as
I like to say.
And I, when I did a segment last week saying
let's debate whether kids in cages deserve
soap or not.
If 20 years ago you go directly to let's cage
kids at places like these and we just have
to figure whether they deserve soap.
That's too crazy too quickly.
And the way that you get us to that point
is by 20 years of slowly normalizing, normalizing
it, normalizing, normalizing.
There's no question that the dehumanize dehumanization,
the dehumanizing rhetoric from the right when
it comes to immigrants and the, the use of
the term illegals and so on has contributed
to this.
So you're correctly pointing out that just
pushing the ball a little bit forward on marginally
improving the conditions at these camps is
simply not enough.
And unfortunately it's going to take more
than one election cycle to fix this.
Number one, obviously it's not just the president,
but it's holding all of our elected officials
accountable for what's going on because they
do have power to influence what the law is
and what protocol is.
But even going beyond that, the entire narrative
around immigrants, including stories of they
take our jobs, they are dangerous criminal,
all of the, it all has to be on done and unfortunately
it's like decades of stuff.
And so I don't know exactly how we start doing
it and I'm not super optimistic that it can
happen quickly.
Okay.
Thank you so much.
Um, I know that like I live in Youngstown,
Ohio and it's hard to get information on this
stuff.
I just found out a couple of weeks ago that
like we are the city that holds the most people
in ice detention for the state.
And I don't even know like exactly where that
is.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Be Nice.
Be able to find out more information on these
things.
Yeah, I just wanted to like shout out at Tim
Ryan for not doing enough on this because
he's running for president right now and he
is our congressman and I haven't heard anything
from him.
You know, I haven't followed his campaign
that closely, but I also have not heard that.
I've heard him talk a lot about manufacturing
in Youngstown, Ohio, but not about, uh, migrant
detention or anything like that.
So I think you're totally right about that.
Okay.
Thank you, David.
All right, I appreciate the phone call.
Thank you very much.
Great to hear from you.